hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve the problem decode ways so
we're basically given a string of
integers and we want to know with that
string of integers how many different
ways can we take that string of integers
and decode it into a string of
characters and we're given a specific
mapping so we have 26 characters and
each integer maps to a different
character so we have an integer 1 2 all
the way to 26 and each of these integers
maps to a different character now we
don't actually need to build that string
that we are mapping to we just have to
count the number of different ways we
can decode it so down here in the
example you can see a string like 12 can
be decoded in two different ways one way
to decode it is just one and two because
one maps to a
two maps to b so that's one string but
remember we can have double digit values
so 12 actually maps to its own character
12 itself maps to 11. so there are two
different ways that this string this
string of integers could be mapped to a
string of characters so we return two in
the output now as you can see it would
be very simple if we just had numbers
one through nine that map to characters
right the problem comes from double
digits right from 10 10 a string like
this can be taken in two different ways
right 1 0 or just 10 right so that's
where the complexity is going to come
from from a string like this we could
have two different decisions so we're
going to be using a decision tree to
kind of figure out all the possibilities
with this at least that's going to be
the brute force approach the only
problem is that there's going to be a
few different edge cases we have to
worry about for example we could have a
string like this we could have a string
like zero
six right how what what exactly does
this map to well zero is not even in our
our input right basically zero itself
does not map to any character right six
could map to a character but zero does
not so if we ever get a zero you know a
string starting with zero that's invalid
so we have to return zero in that case
this cannot be mapped to any uh this
cannot be decoded in any way so we
return zero okay let's try to figure out
the brute force approach to solving this
problem and in doing that we'll try to
figure out some of the edge cases that
we're gonna have to deal with suppose we
have a string like this one two one how
many different ways can this be decoded
well let's say we start at the beginning
right we could take one by itself right
that's going to be some character right
we don't really care what it is but it's
going to be some character now we could
also take the first two characters by
themselves 12 by itself right because
that's valid right so that's another
decision starting from here we could
take one or we could take 12. and by the
way if this was a zero we definitely
could not take it then we'd have to just
stop immediately right because we can't
start with a string starting at zero but
if we had something like one zero right
a ten maybe then we can take it because
it's okay if a zero comes after a one
and so basically any any integer by
itself right one two three four five any
integer by itself except for zero can be
taken right so basically we can create
any string of one
you know one number from one through
nine except zero right we're just not
including zero it cannot be taken by
itself but any from one through nine are
okay right so what we're gonna see here
is okay if we went down this path where
we chose a one then the next character
we're gonna be at is the two right of
course two can be taken by itself right
any number except for zero can be taken
by itself it can be decoded in that way
so when we're at this one or one when
we're at this position we can take two
by itself or we can take 21 right 21 is
also some character i don't know what it
is but remember we had values from 1
through 26 right so having a 20 21 is
completely fine that will decode to its
own character right now of course if we
had something like a 27 over here then
we could not go down this path right
then we just would not go down this path
because 27 does not map to any character
right so we're kind of learning that you
know anything the integers have to be
within 1 through 26 right and this 27 is
not okay and so down this path we reach
the end right we had a 1 and we had a 21
right so there's no more characters to
choose from here so basically this was
one way that we could decode this input
so when we reach the end we're gonna
count that as a one right that means we
found a single way to decode this input
so this was a good base case where we
return one and from here let's continue
this one so we left off at two then we
get to one can one be taken by itself of
course again it's not a zero so we can
take it by itself and so then we reach
the end of the string again so this is
another good base case one two one is a
valid way to decode this string so if we
started with one you know over here we
could decode this in two different ways
if we start with 12 how many ways can we
decode it well if we start with 12 then
we just have one character left the one
character
so that can be decoded another way so
this is another good base case so
basically we saw that we have three
different ways that we can decode this
string now just to kind of add a couple
values to the string what if we had
something like 31 after it so then you
know let's say we left off over here you
know we can choose the three by itself
right because any character except for
zero can be taken by itself could we
take 31 we could not right the same
reason we can't take 27 we can't take 31
because it's it's greater than 26 right
how are we going to determine that in
the code you can do it a lot of
different ways what i'm just going to
say is we can only take double digit
values if the the first digit starts
with a one
because if it starts with a one then for
the second digit we can take anything
from zero to nine right anything from
zero to nine because then you know this
this this double digit value will either
be between 10 to 19 right and this value
is less than 26 so that's perfectly fine
but if we start with a two digit
if we start with a two digit then the
second digit has to be between zero and
six because 26 is going to be less than
or equal to 26 but if this became too
large if it became a 27 that's not less
than or equal to 26 so we can't do that
that's how i'm going to decide it now
what if the first digit started with a 3
you know or or a four or a five or
anything that's never going to work
because if we're going to have some
other second digit here it's never going
to be less than or equal to 26 right
it just won't be so we're only gonna
have uh two decisions right we're only
gonna have two branches if our first
digit is a one or if it is a two so this
is kind of the brute force approach that
i'm showing you but it might not be
super efficient because we could have
two decisions at every single every
single position then our time complexity
would be something like 2 to the power
of n where n is the length of the input
string so how can we kind of do a little
bit better well notice the sub problem
that we're doing for example when we
take when we take just 1 by itself and
consider okay this is just going to be
one way that we decode it then we're
asking okay how many different ways can
we decode the remaining of the string
right that's the sub problem over here
we're asking how many different ways can
we decode 21 when we take the first two
characters 12 then we're asking how many
different ways can we decode the string
one right so that's kind of how the sub
problem is going to work the sub problem
is just going to be some portion of the
string you know for example you know
starting from
from here all the way to the end of the
string how many ways can we decode this
or how many ways can we decode this or
how many ways can we decode the entire
thing right to to be able to solve this
problem how many ways can we decode this
we have to solve the sub problem how
many ways can we decode everything
except the beginning and so basically
you know how many different ways can we
cache it well we're going to have some
index i which could either be here or it
could be here or it could be here it's
just going to designate starting from
here and taking the remaining portion of
the string how many ways can we decode
it so basically the dimension of our
cache is going to be n right so that's
kind of that's also going to be the time
complexity because every time we get to
a position i at most we have two
different decisions to make right so
that's going to be an o of one operation
making those two decisions it's not like
we're gonna have to run through a loop
or anything like that we're not gonna
have any loops and you'll see that when
i write out the code if this is the size
of our cache this is also going to be
the size of our time complexity and this
is also going to be the size of our
memory this is because it's the size of
the cache now just so you know i think
this problem actually can be solved when
we write out the actual dynamic
programming solution not using a cache
not doing it recursively but natural
dynamic programming it can be solved
with of one memory because one thing you
might notice okay when we want to know
how many ways can we decode this entire
string well you know when we're at a
pointer i we can either take this
character by itself in which case then
we're going to shift i by one over here
and ask you know what's the result of
this sub problem or if we take the first
two characters 12 then we're gonna ask
okay what's the result of this sub
problem right so we're either gonna so
basically you know it's a set dp of i
we're either gonna ask dp of i plus one
or i plus two right those are the only
ones that we would need to look at right
to compute a value like this we'd only
need to at most look at two different
positions that come after it so you know
when we have our dp cache we actually
don't need a full array to solve this
problem we could do it with two just two
variables similar to like a house robber
problem approach to dynamic programming
or like a fibonacci sequence problem
right but with that being said i think
we're ready to get into the code now now
let's write the code so the first way
i'm going to show you the solution is
basically the recursive caching solution
the o of n time and memory solution so
we're going to initialize our cache we
are going to put a single value in here
basically the entire length of the
string is going to map to one because if
we get an empty string we want to return
one in that case that's just kind of our
good base case right and then we're
ready to write out the recursive
function i'm just going to call it dfs
pass in a single variable i basically i
is the position that we're at in our
string s now one base case is if i is in
our dp neither meaning either it's
already been cached or i is the last
position in the string in which case
that's our base case right and then we
would just return dp of i so that's you
know our good base case it's either been
cached or you know it's just the end of
the string our bad base case is going to
be if it's not the end of the string
then we have to check what character it
is if the character is starting with
zero right if the string is starting
with zero then it's invalid right
there's no ways to decode a string that
starts with zero so then we have to
return zero so that's like our bad base
case so so these are the two main base
cases that we have but remember if it's
not zero that means it's between one
through nine in which case uh we know we
can take this value as a single digit
right so then the sub problem becomes
dfs of i plus one right so that's what
the result is going to be we're just
going to call dfs on i plus 1 because we
took the character at i as a single
digit right but we know that there are
some cases where we can also call i plus
2. now what's a good way that we can
write out that case well first
let's this is one of the ways you can do
it i'm sure there are better ways but
basically if i plus 1 is less than the
length of the string basically if we do
have a second character that comes after
the current one right because we're
looking for a double digit character so
if i plus one is in bounds and either
the character s of i starts with a one
right s of i is a one because if it
starts with a one and there is a second
digit that means that definitely we can
take a double digit value right because
anything between 10 all the way to 19 is
a double digit value right so if as long
as it starts with one we know we can
make a double digit value or the other
case is basically i'm trying to figure
out a good way to format this in a
readable way but basically or if s of i
is equal to two right it starts with a
two but if it does start with a two then
the second digit right s of i plus one
must be between zero and six right how
can we check that in python at least we
can check okay if this uh character
happens to be in this substring one two
three four five six right basically
we're saying is that second digit any
value between zero through six at least
this is a clean ish way to write it so i
encourage you to reread this uh
condition if you don't fully understand
it but it's basically what i mentioned
in the drawing explanation we're
basically checking if this double digit
value is between 10 to 26 so then we can
actually take it as a double digit value
if we can do that then to our result
we're going to add
dfs of i plus two right it makes sense
we're doing i plus two because this is a
double digit value the sub problem
becomes i plus two and then once we're
done with that we can just go ahead and
return the result but before we do don't
forget to cache it so dp of i is going
to be equal to result we're caching it
and then we're going to return the
result and then uh you know when we
actually want to return the result in
the outer function we can just return
dfs of zero because we want to know how
many ways can we decode the string
starting at index zero and i ran it and
as you can see it works and it's pretty
efficient let me just copy and paste the
actual dynamic programming solution i
don't want to waste too much time to
write it out because it is very similar
and i think if you can come up with the
recursive approach the logic for the
dynamic programming solution is also
pretty simple we have the exact same
cache the only thing is we're doing this
bottom up so we're starting at the end
of the string iterating in reverse order
we have the same base cases basically if
s of i starts with zero then the dp is
going to be zero right and basically you
know this is the same as these two lines
of code where where we just return zero
else meaning you know that means it's a
digit between one through nine then we
can call dp of i plus one that's the
same as when down here when we call dfs
of i plus 1. now this bottom part is the
exact same as the if statement we had
down below right you can see the logic
is the exact same you know the condition
is the exact same only difference is
here we're saying dp of i plus two is
added down here instead of using dp of i
plus two we actually called the
recursive function dfs so this the logic
is definitely pretty similar and in this
solution at least the memory is o of n
but i do think that you can instead of
having an entire cache or array or
whatever you're using you can just have
two variables so i hope that this was
helpful if it was please like and
subscribe it supports the channel a lot
and i'll hopefully see you pretty soon
thanks for watching